рік тому харкові відкрився містечко для
біженців з донбасу та модульної
пляшкою українці на дала не матч на
ерота Віталій віленських так вигляду
хорькова із зони бойових дій ганський
області півторак цього театру видатних
дітей четверо прийомних тоді vitara він у
ким руди на нас поділася і що
зможе atrappo tu німецькою страйк для
праслин сил що до початку будемо дитинство
у jerzy стояв і більше тисячі людей
все багатий вудити не обладнаний з
інвалідом і не скажу, що нам ви 100 чаю
А наскільки ви нам від і квартиру
дорогу то нам вас то чаю нам дали три
пляшечкою та в цех 3 пляшечках нас за
галон же в 20 рон ти чоловік за
проживання тут гуртувати у чавуну всього
110 гр його якщо ден і комунального
витрати бренду собі марія харкова на дим
наші нинішні мешканці не поспішайте
виїжджати з пляшечки біля купа
тривало а що біженці це машка
attitude на я тільки й руку путін відривають
жид ловить держави і звіріти папірець не
так essence послуги допомогу вкладай не
менше наше на початку того спина муза
плагіна та гуманітарного проекту
натиснули дулю татар жеваний маяка якщо ви
Значну стратегію щось треба не
чекала на таких людей
all і захід на ціну не знаєте душити
високим і c було б серйозним стимулом
для того щоб стрибків зі всякими до
нового своє основне завдання а сама була
транзитним проблема в тому що за рік
кільцями страйку нового так і на
смагляві з усієї виклику тася багата до
рослих даси відривати тримав цей папір і
не проти віч белінський тут раніше ви не
відтік всі людині з сієрру даною
значний роботу та ринок ремонту та відпочинок
на замовлення по луганській області
он і за вийшов і п'ять квартир і навряд
чи зможете у харкові
квітці заруби ти хоч одну одну думку то
малюка українців про що вже до в Україні
вид по видно травня ніби закон щоб нам
треба ви обидва хоча б компенсував це ж
логіці ми за вийшов і на окупованих
територіях
відведення на проживання модульних пляшечок
добиваючи кінсі а вранці
та й ринок же розпад йшла активна
охолодження за рядів теми з би міг би ви
вирішіть їх не жити нове харчування